all we as families have asked for from
day one is the truth acknowledgment of
failures
the determination to make sure that
those failures are fixed so that next
time because there will be your next
time
but hopefully next time there won't be
as many families going through the utter
heartbreak we have had to endure for the
last five years nine months one week and
one day
we didn't get that acknowledgment from
anyone other than gmfrs until the
Chairman's reports were published shame
on you all
in this volume of the report the chair
has recognized that where there was a
significant missed Opportunity by MI5
which had their taken action could
ultimately have changed the course of
what happened that night
he also identified a lack of information
sharing between the police and the
security services we hope lessons really
will be learned this time
however there were some Heroes that
night and to name a few Sergeant come
here inspector Mike Smith Chief
Inspector Mark Dexter and civilians
Bethany crook Ronald Blake and Darren
Costa this is where the medals should
have gone
we have sat through eight weeks in the
old daily in over two years here at the
inquiry
we've read countless statements listened
to hours of evidence and we can only
hope that one day the whole truth will
come out and others including the
fugitive brother and parents face
Justice because we will never believe
they were in this alone
forgiveness will never be an option for
such evil intentions and those that
played any part in the murder of our
children will never ever get forgiveness
from top to bottom MI5 to the associate
of the attacker we will always believe
that you all played a part in the murder
of our children
we will spend the rest of our lives
trying to protect our boys
because as we found out through this
process once you leave the safety of
your home you are on your own
so many people being paid that night to
protect our kids and yet so many failed
in their duties professionals that had
responsibility but clearly had other
priorities
security staff that even when told of
the danger failed to act appropriately
once again we'll never forgive you
nothing can bring Liam and Chloe back
nothing
but we won't let them be forgotten
we've set up a charity in their names as
a lasting Legacy to show that from such
an absolute heartbreak something
positive can rise we will continue to
campaign
to be allowed to register the personal
deal on their death certificates and we
won't rest until all those who play the
role in their deaths are brought to
Justice
can we finally thank Duncan Atkinson
Casey Victoria Ailes and Adam Peter for
being our voice throughout this ordeal
and our amazing team from Hogan levels
and Scott Haley and Helen for their
constant support even on the darkest
days you will never know how much this
meant was the families including